[MUSIC PLAYING]
MORGAN DOLLARD: I'm really
excited to be here today,
and we have an incredible
lineup of products and speakers
in store for you today.
There's never been a better time
to turn your passion for games
into a business.
Mobile gaming remains the
fastest growing segment
of the games industry, and
Android and Google Play
are at the forefront
of that growth.
Google Play has the most
vibrant, diverse and engaged
gaming community.
Gaming on Android is
a global phenomenon,
with Google Play
reaching more than 1
billion monthly active users
in more than 190 countries.
Every year we see more
and more developers
finding success on our platform,
and over the past year,
the number of games with
over 1 million installs
has increased by 50%.
That's amazing momentum,
and we're incredibly
excited to see you succeed.
So as remarkable as
these numbers are,
you, the games developers, are
the real heroes of this story.
The contributions of developers
like many of you in the room
were integral to the
adoption of Android.
So let's give a round of
applause for all the developers
that helped Android succeed.
[APPLAUSE]
Everything my team and
teams across Google do
are inspired by you,
the games developers,
and the games you make.
You are the ones that
take big risks, that
are pursuing your
passion for games,
for many a passion
since childhood.
You eat, sleep, and
breathe video games.
If you're inspired by
great games, as we are,
you want to build great games.
You want to create a
new style of gameplay,
find a clever hack
to get the best
performance from your hardware,
or make your mark on VR gaming.
Once you've built
an amazing game,
you want people to
discover it, and enjoy it.
For that, you need to find
users, the right users,
the ones that will
love your game
and make it a critical success.
Most of you in here don't
do this as a hobby, though.
You have to turn your
awesome game into a business
so you can keep making games.
Are you going to
go free-to-play,
are you going to
sell a premium game,
are you going to use
in-app advertising?
There are some tough
choices to make,
and every game has to
find the right balance.
If you have done these
things, then of course
you'll want to turn a game
into an ongoing service
to deliver to players,
to keep them coming
for new content, new
goals, and new ways
for them to share their
experience with others.
For the next few
minutes, we'll show you
how we can help you, the hero
of the story, be successful.
So let's talk about
making great games.
Think about the
games you've played,
the ones that inspired you to
build games in the first place.
What's common among
the best games
is that they find something
new to deliver to players.
They push the boundaries
of graphics and sounds
by integrating deeply with
the platforms they run on.
Mobile technology
is moving fast.
We now have a generation
of mobile devices
that are near console quality,
and you need powerful tools
to make them perform.
And Google is
working to bring you
the newest and best tools to
take full advantage of these
on Android.
Last week, we announced
the Android N preview,
and this year we're trying to
give you earlier access so you
can build and test your
games with the latest
generation of Android.
Android N contains a lot of new
features for users, including
improved battery
life and performance,
new interactions
for large screens,
improved accessibility, and
some new security features.
And for game developers, we
have some exciting additions
to Android N. OpenGL
ES 3.2 support, which
includes great features
like geometry, tessellation
changes, and ASTC
compression; and also includes
new multi-window features,
including support
for split screen on
phones and tablets,
as well as picture-in-picture
for Android TV.
For data plan
constrained players,
N offers Data Saver, a
foreground-only data usage
mode, and you'll also be
able to take advantage
of new notification features
like notification bundling
and new customization options
for relevant notifications.
Your games also
need to look great,
so a big part of the upcoming
Android platform is Vulkan.
Vulkan is a new 3D
rendering API which
we've helped to develop as a
member of the industry group
Khronos, which develops open
graphics standards like OpenGL
ES.
Vulkan provides explicit
low-overhead GPU control
to developers.
Let's take an example of that,
of Vulkan running on Android.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This is our Fish Tornado running
on the Android SHIELD TV.
This demo runs both on desktop
and [AUDIO OUT], the same code,
the same shaders, the same C+.
The cross-platform shaders
would have been much harder
with OpenGL ES.
Vulkan's render pass
system enables Fish Tornado
to take advantage of
multi-pass rendering
in ways you couldn't
have with OpenGL ES.
[END PLAYBACK]
In January, we announced
the Spatial Audio edition
to the Cardboard SDK.
Many apps create simple
versions of Spatial Audio
by playing sounds from the left
and right in separate speakers,
but with this SDK
[AUDIO OUT], your app
can produce sound the same
way humans actually hear it.
All your players need is their
smartphone, their headphones,
and their Google
Cardboard viewer.
Overall, the SDK
allows more [AUDIO OUT]
3D specializations via modeling
the physiology of your head.
This SDK update
gives you the ability
to put your players in tiny
spaceships, huge caverns,
with even better performance.
Graded audio like this can
make for very immersive games
and virtual reality apps.
So why do you make games?
To entertain and delight
your players, of course.
For that to happen, you
actually need players.
Google has a number
of ways for you
to find and engage
with your audience.
Advertisers have long
been able to control
who sees their AdWords ads,
and in the coming weeks,
we'll be launching
even finer options
to reach high-quality users
with active user targeting
for games.
This new type of
targeting for Android apps
can show active users who have
spent more than 30 minutes
playing games, or played
a Google Play Games
integrated game.
Game developers can show
their ads to game lovers,
and combined with other
types of targeting,
such as a particular
game category,
they can reach a very
precise audience.
Video is also a
powerful way to let
users see gameplay, graphics,
and features before downloading
the app.
And we've been exploring
ways to give developers
more opportunities
to connect with users
or view their game videos
on their mobile device,
and we've discovered
that over 80%
of video ad views in mobile apps
on the Google Display Network
start from the devices
held vertically.
Over the next few weeks, we're
launching portrait video ads,
so users can see a fullscreen,
immersive, portrait video
experience, without having
to reorient their device.
We've seen significant
improvements
in both click-throughs
and conversion rates
from game developers
using portrait video,
resulting in a much
lower cost per install
and a larger number
of downloads.
Search Trial Run Ads
will be in beta soon,
and will allow
users to stream apps
directly from ads
on Google Search.
With this new ad format, we're
making it significantly easier
for you to promote your games
while giving users a chance
to try a game for
up to 10 minutes
before choosing to download it
directly from Google Search.
This is a great way to
drive highly qualified users
to your game.
For those of you who
are indie developers,
you'll be excited to hear we're
adding a new way to highlight
you and your games with a new
Indie Corner in the Play Store.
The Indie Corner is
dedicated to highlighting
truly amazing and unique
indie games that users love.
Here's how it works.
First, you have to
make a great game.
Submit your game to
participate in the program.
[AUDIO OUT] games
are then featured
in the Indie Corner collection
in the Google Play Store.
If your game gets
traction with users
and achieves
critical acclaim, it
can ascend and be featured
in the Indie Masterpiece
[AUDIO OUT], which highlights
the very best games on Google
Play.
Check it out today.
The Indie Corner collection
is live on the store.
Last month, we launched
gamer IDs and avatars
to give users an improved
Google Play Games experience.
Users can choose
their own gamer ID
and avatar, set their privacy
preferences [AUDIO OUT]
automatically sign into games.
Our sign-in improvements
also benefit developers.
Automatic sign-in can
make it easier and faster
for players to
start playing games.
In the next few months, we'll be
adding Gamer Friends to Google
Play Games so that players
can build connections
with their friends or gamers
they interact with in-game.
So you can see some screenshots
of how this will work.
You can find other players based
on either our recommendations
or invite them to
become friends,
manage your invitations
through our Inbox,
and choose to accept or
ignore requests to connect.
And you'll be able to see what
games your friends are playing,
helping users discover
new and amazing content
that they might not know about.
Gameplay videos are a great
way to drive viral growth
for your games.
Late last year, we made
it possible for users
to record their gameplay with
the Google Play Games app.
Today, we're announcing
that in the coming months,
players will have the option to
livestream their gameplay, as
well.
We'll also be
providing an API that
enables you to easily
add video recording
and livestreaming to your games.
Monetizing your game is an
important part of this journey.
You can, of course, monetize
directly through Google Play,
by using in-app purchases,
selling your premium game,
or using in-app advertising.
Today, we're launching rewarded
ads via AdMob Mediation.
You can now grow your
app's overall ad revenue
by adding reward-based ads
from third-party providers
to your app via AdMob Mediation.
Reward-based video
ads enable users
to earn in-game currency
or items of value
in exchange for viewing ads.
You choose a reward amount,
you experiment as often
as you like to find
the optimal amount,
without having to resubmit your
app to the stores for approval.
AdMob Mediates the ads,
choosing the ones which
can earn you the most, and ads
will come from third parties.
We have certified adapters for
leading rewarded ads providers,
such as Chartboost, Vungle,
AppLovin, AdColony, Fyber,
Upsight, Unity, and
many more coming.
And now, I'd like to
introduce Ben Frenkel, who
is a product manager for Play
Games Developer Experiences.
[APPLAUSE]
BEN FRENKEL: Thank you, Morgan.
All right, so now you have a
great game, a growing audience,
and hopefully, hopefully
you've made some revenue.
And as much time and effort as
you spent working on your game
pre-launch, it's
post-launch we can
gather enough data
about your users
to finish tuning your game.
That's why it's important
to think about your game
as an ongoing service you
can deliver to players.
You need to think about
your games as a service.
And you need to do three
things-- three things--
to manage your
games as a service.
You need to be able to
dynamically make changes
to the way your games
behave, tailor and optimize
game experiences for
different player segments,
and you need the tools
to deeply understand
what's working and not
working for your players.
Most developers that manage
their games as a service
can dynamically change almost
everything about the way
their games behave
from their servers,
and the best at
this control almost
every aspect of
their game, including
their virtual good inventory,
their in-game economy balance,
the difficulty of
their game, and even
what promotions to run.
It's a lot of hard work
to set up and manage
these types of services,
and if you're not
a large studio with a dedicated
server engineering team,
every single minute you
spend on this type of work
takes away from the thing
you're really passionate about,
which is making games.
Well, no more.
We are excited to announce
that Play Games Game Parameters
Management will be launching
in the coming months
to make it simple to dynamically
manage the parameters that
drive your game.
With Game Parameters
Management, you'll
be able to manage your
virtual good inventory
and gameplay parameters, manage
your different currencies,
and create time- and
location-based value overrides.
The time- and
location-based overrides
are particularly powerful.
Many developers that offer
time-limited content,
like a new character
or a weapon, still
have to manually turn on
and off these promotions.
So let's say, for example,
you had a promotion that
ended at 11:59 on a Sunday;
you might need someone
from your team to go into
the office and physically
turn off the promotion.
There's got to be a
better way to do it.
And if you're running a
global games business,
you want your promotions to be
run at locally relevant times.
And with our time- and
country-based overrides,
you'll be able to specify
country-specific start and stop
times, and we'll automatically
manage everything for you.
And we've been working with
our partner, Concrete Software,
throughout the development of
Game Parameters Management,
and they are the real
heroes of the story.
They're the ones that inspired
us to build the Game Parameter
Management service, because
we saw the opportunity
to make it easier and
faster and cheaper
and less error-prone
for Concrete Software
to manage their
games as a service.
And we're really
fortunate today to have
Keith, the CEO of Concrete
Software, in the audience.
Keith, do you want to
wave your hand over there?
Excellent.
So Keith and the
Concrete Software team
have run their first
end-to-end promotion
using Game Parameters
Management over the weekend,
and from all the
reports I've heard,
it's been a tremendous success.
So let's give a round
of applause for Keith
and the Concrete Software team.
[APPLAUSE]
Woo!
Go, Keith.
And in Keith's own words,
Game Parameters Management
will drastically cut
setup time and issues,
while allowing us to create
all kinds of new promotions
we couldn't previously,
and they're looking forward
to including Game
Parameters Management in all
of their future games.
So last year we launched
the Player Stats API,
which allowed you to create
tailored game experiences
for every player segment.
We provided segment data
based on percentile sessions
and spend, average session
length, and so forth.
We also gave you predictions
for whether or not someone is
going to spend or
churn from your games.
The Player Stats API is
another powerful tool for you
to run your games as
a service, and it's
available for free today.
Developer Underwater Apps
has a killer application
of the Player Stats API.
They integrated Player Stats
into their flagship title, Tap
Ventures, and used the
spend prediction signal
to determine whether or not
they would show ads to users.
If a user was
predicted to spend,
they didn't see any ads
at all, and for users
that were not
predicted to spend,
they would see ads every single
time they opened up the game.
Then they ran an experiment that
compared their current approach
to serving ads to the new
and improved approach powered
by spend prediction, and the
results speak for themselves.
Revenue from ads was 17%
higher in the cohort predicted
not to spend, and
not showing ads
to users that were
probable to spend increased
the number of IAP
transactions by 15%.
That's huge impact,
and we couldn't
be more excited for them.
And we've continued to
invest in new predictions
to make the Player Stats
API even more powerful,
and we're excited to announce
two new predictions will be
available in the coming months.
The first is a prediction
of how much someone
will spend in the next
30 days, and the second
predicts the probability a user
will become a high spender.
And we couldn't be more
excited to see what
creative things you'll end up
doing with these new tools.
At last year's GDC, we
launched the first version
of Player Analytics, and we've
made significant investments
in uMetrics and uReports,
and most recently, we
launched the Cohorts
and Funnel Reports
to help you track the
impact of new game features
you've added to your game, learn
where and why you are losing
users, and to understand
the differences in behavior
between people who don't
spend any money at all,
people who spend a little bit
of money, and your big spenders.
And if you haven't had a chance
to check out Player Analytics
before, you can go to
the Developer Console
today and see the
reports, see how they work
with one of our sample games.
And we've heard from developers
that Player Analytics has had
a big impact on their business.
Developer Max Games has been
using Player Analytics to help
understand where and why
they are losing players
in their game Stick Wars:
Legacy, and with that data,
they can focus
their improvements
to most efficiently
improve retention.
Max Games used the Funnel
Report to identify levels
in Stick Wars with
above-average churn,
and here's what Jason,
their CEO, had to say.
"The Funnel Report is vital
to balancing our game Stick
Wars: Legacy, and using the
Play Games Funnel Report,
we were able to reduce
churn in level six by 40%."
That's incredible impact.
40% more users now
get to experience
the rest of the game.
And of course, since then
the bottleneck has moved,
and they've identified
more opportunities
to reduce churn even further.
So there you have it.
You have new tools to
create the best games,
find the right audience,
monetize that audience,
and grow your game as an
intelligent, living service.
And remember, you
are the real heroes
of the story, the developers,
and all of these products
and all these people
here from Google
are working for you to help make
your business more successful.
So go out there,
make awesome games,
and be the heroes
we know you can be.
With that, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]